welcome back to us s so thousands of
people rallied in Washington today
against surging anti-semitic attacks
since the Israel Hamas conflict began
incidents in the US is Spike by nearly
400% people from all over the nation
have traveled to the March for Israel
which also demanded a release of
hostages taken by Hamas we're from
Washington I'm joined Now by
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
whose new book called MTG is out soon
well welcome MTG um you are a very thank
you for having me on my pleasure you're
a very contr verial character depending
who I talk to they say you're an
absolute fire brand the female Donald
Trump others say you're a conspiracy
theory wack job how do you
plead well I'm only controversial
because people like you made it that way
Pierce and that's why I wrote my book
MTG what have I done H people people in
your industry they created a character
of me that doesn't exist and so I wrote
my book MTG so that I could tell my
country and tell the world exactly who I
am and what my real views are which are
not radical they are not controversal
they're actually very American and they
represent the views of not only my
district but most Americans who are sick
and tired of being sell out by
Washington so you never promote
ridiculous conspiracy
theories well if you mean by Russian
collusion absolutely not those are the
conspiracy theories and the lies of the
Democrats and the media age you I never
promoted those I agree with you about
that it was ridiculous I said so at the
time well there was no yeah and we were
born out but for example I want to play
a clip from a guy called Bassam YF he
was known as the Arab John Stewart and I
interviewed him recently about the the
war and he said this about
you the saddest thing that I saw is the
people that were in so much support of
Israel are anti-semite themselves MTG
MTG MTG uh Mery Taylor green you know
she said like oh those are I send my
AIDS and they took pictures of the
protesters basically she's surveilling
protesters and M Taylor green is very
known for a very famous Post in 2018
where she blamed the California wildfire
fires on a Jewish space laser
gun now you did didn't you cuz I've read
that post I went and got it and I read
it uh November 17 2018 you posted a long
thing on Facebook that was just complete
gobbley go I mean you made out that the
child I talk about Jewish space
lasers something I never said no excuse
me I never said that phrase that was a
lie about me if you read my original
Facebook post I never said and that's
why I had to write this book because
people like you and whoever that guy was
sounds like one of the trolls in my
social media attacking me and calling me
names when he's never met me um I'm not
anti at all I support Israel and I am
outraged at Hamas attacking innocent
Israeli citizens women children call
sling babies I'm not calling you
anything I'm just saying that you did
post this uh crazy post basically
alleging that you know I know no you
know the media lied about it and that's
why I wrote my book Piers because I'm
setting the record straight and I hope
people order my book at MTG book.com
it's a great reading people need to know
exactly who I am who I am and what I
really believe in it's a very good it's
a very good plug for the book but you
did suggest in this post which I've read
very carefully you did suggest that the
California wildfires at the time had
been started by pg& in conjunction with
the Ross Charles using a a a space laser
in order to clear room for a High-Speed
Rail Project they're your words not
mine well you know people have twisted
my words Non-Stop and I guess that's
what you're going to continue to do but
we're working hard America to straight
out our problems you are you're doing a
great job of it peers and that's what
you and your colleagues do all the time
I just don't I don't handle it I don't
deal with it and I cast it to the side
you know there's a lot of issues
happening that we could talk about talk
about but before you before we move on
though you have to just accept what you
wrote yourself don't you you deleted it
you obviously you were embarrassed by it
well that would be like that would be
like me asking you to accept the fact
that you defended prisoners at
Guantanamo Bay but never say anything
about January 6 defendants who are
having their rights abused and are
rotting away in solitary confinement
here in our country and especially in
the DC jail you know if we're going to
talk about each other's words let's hold
each other to account to issues that
really matter not social media posts
from the I don't know what you're
referring to on guantan Mo Bay but what
I would say about guantan Mo Bay is it's
clearly ridiculous that America kept
this open-ended camp where people were
kept without trial sometimes for more
than 12 years it's completely ridiculous
in a civilized Democratic Society that
you would do that now let's move on from
my words well in a in a civilized
Democrat Society we shouldn't be holding
American citizens that simply walk
through the capital grandmothers and
mothers and Veterans walking through the
capital never doing anything wrong and
they're rotting away in jail and being
persecuted by our department of justice
and our government that has has
completely gone out of control so if
you're going to talk about one we should
talk about the other let's talk about
January 6th by all means I mean I know
what I witnessed with my own eyes and it
was a huge violent were you here it was
sorry were you here no I watched it on
television you weren't here oh I was
here Pierce let me tell you I was here I
was actually in the house chamber
because I objected to Joe Biden's
Electoral College votes yeah um I'm very
proud of that I would object again today
if I could you did suggest that people I
was there you did suggest that people
use violence to to thwart democracy
didn't
he not well you mean like in 1776 when
we beat your country is that what you're
talking about if you want refence I
didn't talk about violence on you want
reference 1776 I did talk about is
objecting using my constitutional Duty
that I
have to object to
fraud let me what abely did let me play
you what you said let's let's play what
you said your own words this is an
important time in our history we can't
can't allow this just to just to be gone
you know just to let it go you can't
allow it to just transfer power
peacefully like Joe Biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he did not win this election
it's being stolen and the evidence is
there the so there can be no peaceful
transfer of power so what's the opposite
of Peace that's why we objected peers
that's why we objected
and that I as a member of Congress okay
let me make my there was a law firm that
tried to take me off the ballot and they
were laughed out of the courtroom in
Georgia and you were giving their
talking points I can't tell you how much
people in Georgia would think let me
give you my talking point which is that
a huge mob of people many of whom were
violent crashed into the capital to try
and thwart
democracy because people like you Mar
people you said two things you mean like
the proas Riders no I'm talking occupied
our capital on October
18th self question wait we're we're in
2023 had a proas m you've written a book
you talk about theseal rash can I ask
you a
question can
I let me ask you the question I want to
ask two questions one presumably when
you say there could be no peaceful
transfer of power you mean there has to
be some violent objection to it which is
exactly what we then saw on January 6 I
didn't say violence I
didn't going to let you do that no PE
I'm not going to let you you're lying
I'm not letting you put words in my
mouth that I never said absolutely not
you want to know where the real election
interference happened it happened with
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama and
Russian through hell for four years
agreed with you I've agreed with you
about Russian collusion let's agree
about that but let's not agree about the
St election I told Donald Trump to his
face and he didn't like it called me a
fool seven times that the election was
not stolen from him he has singularly
failed to produce any actual hard
evidence that there was any stolen
election do you still believe that
election was
stol Piers you're not even a voter in
our country and I can tell you right now
as a Georgia resident and a member of
Congress in Georgia our secretary of
state illegally changed the laws so did
Wisconsin so did Pennsylvania to allow
our states to be flooded with absentee
ballots we have cases in court today you
should look them up Fulton County case
these are cases that are about to be
heard in the next few months peers
excuse me we're about to prove those
cases it you can you can think that all
you want but you live over in Britain
I'm an American I'm a Georgia voter I'm
a member of Congress I've seen the
evidence our election was stolen in 2020
and we are going to re president Trum
what you're going to do but just for the
record I do have a home in America and I
spend a lot of time in America and I
have lived and worked in America for 20
years I love America I love Americans I
particularly love your democratic system
and I don't like to see elected
officials in America whether it's you or
Donald Trump pretending you had an
election stolen when there is actually
no evidence it was stolen and in fact
many senior Republicans age evidence if
you want if you aren't able to if you
aren't capable of of believing the truth
that's your problem prove it in the
courts it is being proven it is County
case look up George Court in the right
now St election Piers don't lie to your
viewers there are call you a liar oh so
you're telling me
suit P from under the table Marie I
don't I'm not calling you a li you watch
the videos STS of ballots being put
through as I said to Donald counted over
and over Marie as I said to Donald Trump
I'm not saying you're lying I'm just
saying produce the evidence because no
court in America has so far established
any evidence that that election was
stolen it's for the birds it's Cloud
Cuckoo Stu that's because those cases
were dismissed on standing but we have
cases coming up Pi pay attention so that
if you really viers to know the truth
pay attention to these cases happening
right now let's talk do you have
anything in 2023 do you have cuz we've
done January 6 stolen election
okay what do you got got a book how
about my book MTG this is going MTG
book.com talking about you plugged it
enough you plugged it enough let me ask
you is Donald Trump going to win the
election absolutely he's blowing it out
of the water the primary is a joke and
he is winning poll after poll on the
general election and if he gets
convicted of one of the Myriad criminal
offenses he's been charged with and is
if I'm not saying when if if he is
convicted and he gets a jail sentence
will he be president from a prison
cell absolutely people are going to vote
for him even if he is in jail I would
vote for him even if he's in jail
because we have communism in our country
peers we have the Biden Administration
that is using the Department of Justice
like the campaign arm of the Biden
campaign it's it's unbelievable and
Americans know this that's why people
that are Independents Democrats many
voters are switching over to supporting
president Trump because they're seeing
it for the first time in their lifetimes
okay Marjorie we got to leave it there
it was a lively encounter come back
again uh and thank you for coming on I
appreciate it thanks
Pier